parado sobre los cristales rotos y los
escombros fuera de un edificio los
residentes de gerson desmoronados
observan como los trabajadores de
emergencia vienen a recoger los cuerpos
de sus familiares muertos
los odio esta gente se llevó a las
personas más valiosas de mi vida mis
padres
pero tengo un hijo y debo Vivir por él
adentro la gente empieza a limpiar y los
vecinos se consuelan unos a otros
[Música]
el jueves el edificio Residencial fue
alcanzado por los ataques aéreos rusos
dirigidos contra la ciudad recientemente
liberada los trabajadores también
recogieron los cuerpos dentro de un
coche y en la calle las autoridades de
gerson señalaron que al menos 15 civiles
murieron en los ataques que continuaron
este viernes
el 25 de noviembre los ocupantes
llevaron a cabo un bombardeo masivo
contra edificios residenciales se
produjo un grave incendio y daños 58
personas de las cuales 22 eran niños
fueron evacuadas
los residentes han comenzado a huir de
la ciudad mientras que según el
gobernador de la región de gerson los
pacientes del hospital también han sido
evacuados